Me gustaría contarles acerca de un proyecto
que empezé hace alrededor de 16 años,
y que trata sobre la creación de nuevas formas de vida.
Y son creadas a partir de este tipo de tubo --
tubo eléctrico, le llamamos en Holanda
-- y podemos empezar un video sobre eso
y ver un poco atrás en el tiempo.
Narrador: Eventualmente estas bestias vivirán en manadas en las playas
Theo Jansen está trabajando duro en esta evolución
Theo Jansen: Yo quiero poner estas formas de vida en las playas.
Y éstas deberían sobrevivir allí,
por sí solas, en el futuro.
Aprendiendo a vivir por sí mismas,
y tomará un par de años más para dejarlas caminar por sí solas.
Narrador: Las bestias mecánicas no obtendrán su energía de la comida, sino del viento.
El viento moverá plumas en su dorso, lo cual impulsará sus patas.
La bestia camina de costado sobre la arena mojada de la playa,
con su trompa apuntando hacia el viento.
Tan pronto se encuentra con el oleaje o la arena seca, se detiene,
y camina en la dirección opuesta
La evolución ha generado muchas especies.
Esta es "Animaris Currens Ventosa"
(Aplauso)
Jansen: Esta es una manada, y está construida de acuerdo a códigos genéticos,
y es un tipo de raza, y cada uno de los animales es diferente,
y los códigos ganadores se multiplicarán.
Esta es la ola, yendo de izquierda a derecha, aquí se puede ver.
Y ahora va de -- sí, ahora va de izquierda a derecha.
Esta es una nueva generación, una nueva familia,
que es capaz de almacenar el viento.
Las alas bombean aire hacia botellas de limonada
que están encima de eso --
y pueden usar esta energia en caso de que no haya viento.
Si la marea está subiendo, y todavía queda un poco de energía
pueden alcanzar las dunas y salvar sus vidas, ya que se ahogan muy fácilmente.
(Risa)
Podría mostrarles este animal.
(Aplauso) Gracias.
La proporción de los tubos en este animal es muy importante para poder caminar.
Hay 11 numeros, los cuales llamo los 11 números sagrados.
Estos son, las distancias de los tubos que los hacen caminar de ese modo.
De hecho, es una nueva invención de la rueda.
Funciona igual que la rueda.
El eje de la rueda se mantiene en un mismo nivel,
y esta cadera se mantiene en un mismo nivel tambien.
De hecho, ésto es aún mejor que la rueda, porque
cuando intentas manejar con tu bicicleta por la playa,
te darás cuenta de que es muy difícil hacerlo.
Y las patas simplemente pisan sobre la arena,
mientras que la rueda tiene que tocar cada parte del piso.
Asi que, 5,000 años después de la invención de la rueda,
tenemos una nueva rueda. Y les mostraré en el siguiente video
-- ¿puede comenzarlo, por favor? --
que se pueden mover cargas muy pesadas.
Hay una persona empujando por detrás,
pero también puede caminar muy bien con el viento.
Pesa 3.2 toneladas.
Y éste está funcionando con el viento almacenado en las botellas.
Tiene un tentáculo con el que puede sentir obstáculos y voltearse.
Y esa parte, ven, está yendo en la dirección opuesta.
¿Podrían pasarme el tentáculo?
Ok. Bien.
Así que, tienen que sobrevivir todos los peligros de la playa,
y uno de los grandes peligros es el mar. Este es el mar.
Debe sentir el agua del mar.
Este es el tentáculo para percibir el agua.
Lo que es muy importante es este tubo. Normalmente succiona el aire,
pero cuando traga agua, siente su resistencia.
Así que imaginen que el animal está caminando hacia el mar.
Tan pronto como toca el agua se debería escuchar una especie de succión de aire.
¡Si! Así que, si no siente, se ahogará, ¿OK?
Aquí tenemos el cerebro del animal.
De hecho, es un contador a pasos y cuenta el número de pasos.
Es un contador a pasos binario.
Así que, tan pronto como ha estado en el mar,
cambia el patrón de ceros y unos aqui,
y siempre sabe en qué lugar de la playa está. Así que, es un cerebro muy simple.
Dice: bueno allí está el mar, allí están las dunas, y yo estoy aquí.
Así que es una especie de imaginacion de el mundo simple del animal de playa.
Gracias.
Uno de los enemigos más grandes son las tormentas.
Esta es una parte de la trompa del "Animaris Percipiere",
y cuando su trompa esta fija, todo el animal esta fijo.
Así que cuando se acerca la tormenta,
éste clava un perno en el suelo. (Risas)
Y como la trompa queda fija, todo el animal queda fijo.
El viento puede cambiar de dirección, pero el animal siempre apuntará su trompa hacia el viento.
En un par de años, estos animales podrán sobrevivir por sí mismos.
Todavía tengo que ayudarlos mucho.
Muchas gracias, señoras y señores.
(Aplauso)